moi ce que je fous avec pi c'est qu'on
retrouve vraiment partout des gens
géométrie bien sûr parce que piller
comme vous savez très bien défini comme
le ratio de la circonférence du cercle
par son diamètre est ce qui est déjà fou
c'est que ces voix en fête pour tous les
cercles même si vous prenez un sac qui a
fait le tour de l'univers tout entier
prenez sa circonférence diviser le par
son diamètre vous obtenez dit autre
chose incroyable prenez un bout de
ficelle et fait le tour de la terre
devinez combien il faut rajouter à ce
bout de ficelle pour que lorsqu'on est
temps de la ficelle on obtient
maintenant une ficelle qui soit partout
un mètre au dessus du niveau du sol
il faut ajouter deux fois puis m mais si
pie est si floue ce qui apparaît bien
ailleurs qu en géométrie par exemple une
des formules les plus folles qui existe
est une formule due à un certain mas
d'avall indien du 14e siècle qui dit que
pi est exactement égal à 4 - 4/3 +4/5
moncade 7e ex itéra jusqu'à l'infini
il est où le cercle là est en fait qu on
joue avec des nombre infini de nombre
assez simple comme ça on obtient
rapidement des trucs incroyables
le maître en la matière a été incertain
leonhard euler qui a prouvé entre autres
que la somme des inverse d'écart et un
plus un car plus un neuvième plus un 16e
et c'est jusqu'à l'infini était égal
exactement à picard et sur 6 pourquoi
pical sur six
elle a surtout prouvé une formule
incroyable qui relie api aux autres
nombre incroyable et mathématiques
la fameuse formule e hippie +1 est égal
à zéro donc puis apparaît beaucoup dans
ces sommes infinie et en analysant
général mepi apparaît aussi de façon
surprenante en arithmétique
prenez de nombreux hasard et regarder
leur facteur premier la probabilité
qu'ils n'aient aucun facteur en commun
est si sûre picard et
et puis apparaît aussi en probabilité
prenez une ardoise et tracer des traits
horizontaux séparer de deux fois la
longueur d'une aiguille et jeter plein
d'aiguilhe sur cette feuille est bien la
probabilité d'une aiguille intercepte
une ligne va est égal à 1 sur pie enfin
pu y apparaît aussi en musique de façon
un petit peu caché cette fois les
découvertes fondamentales de l'histoire
de la musique et qu'on pouvait résumer
la musique on les fréquences qui sont
joués c'est pour ça qu'on a des
partitions qui monte les fréquences qui
sont joués plutôt que le signal sonore
qui en fait des perturbations de l'air
pas de l'air polaire mais de l'air bref
il y a une connexion intime est
extrêmement importante entre le signaler
les variations de la pression on joue et
les fréquences qui nous permettent
d'écrire les partitions de la musique
eh ben tu le lien entre les deux c'est
ce qu'on appelle la transformée de
fourier et quand on transfère l'an
l'autre puis l'autre bien de façon assez
mystique apparaissent fameux nombre pi
est donc ce qui est vraiment un crabe à
l'épicé qu'il a été inventé pour de la
géométrie mais il apparaît également en
analyse en arithmétique en probabilités
et même en musique ou plutôt en théorie
de foyers mais ce n'est pas le plus fou
avec pi croyez moi ce qui est pour moi
le plus fou avec pi ce n'est pas tant ce
qu'on sait de lui mais plutôt ce que
l'on ne sait pas de lui et pendant
longtemps on n'a pas su grand chose de
lui puis vraiment insaisissable en grec
antique la légende des mathématiques
était incertain pythagore et je parle
bien de légende parce que son existence
n'est pas avéré bref pythagore avait
trouvé l'harmonie de la musique à
travers des ratios de nombres entiers et
du coup ils pensaient bien sûr que tout
était fait de ratio dentier en tout cas
tous ceux qui étaient jolies ce qu'il
aura sur les jantes d'ailleurs conduit à
noyers l'un de ses disciples pour avoir
osé révéler au monde entier que racine
carrée de 2 n'est pas un ratio est
d'ailleurs pu non plus n'est pas un
ratio pinet pas un ratio pis
n'est pas rationnel qui est irrationnel
donc paye et irrationnel sans doute un
petit peu comme ces politiciens de
l'imzad qui à la fin du 19e siècle
n'arrivant pas à capturer pis on choisit
peu imposée par la loi une valeur api
par la loi ils ont voté et que pays est
égal à 3,5
pendant ce temps les mathématiciens ont
cherché à capturer pied avec leurs
outils préférés c'est à dire les
équations mepi ne peut pas être capturé
avec des équations non plus car pis
dépasse algébrique pillet
transcendantale et donc tout ça c'est ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui de pi mais le
plus chaud avec pi c'est plutôt ce qu'on
ne sait pas de lui aujourd'hui on ne
sait même pas s'il y est un nombre
normal commence à la normale il est déjà
transcendantale comment peut-il être
normal eux aussi fait la plupart des
noms normaux sont transcendantaux et
vice versa c'est un petit peu bizarre
et du coup c'est quoi un nombre normal
un nombre est normal si c'est décimales
ont l'air assez aléatoire ouais je sais
que ce que je ne dira pas l'air très
mathématique mais il a une façon fort
musée ça joue la sûre en tout cas ce qui
est fou si un nombre est normal ou même
vu style et un nombre l'hiver c'est que
si vous prenez n'importe quel nombre
eh bien vous le retrouverez dans les
décimales de pi si vous chercher assez
loin dans l'ailé si mal et ça en se
rendre ça encore un peu plus fou si on
passe à une autre base que la base dit
pas son nom qu'en base 27 où chaque
chiffre va être une lettre de l'alphabet
et la 27e
lettre va être l'espace du coup quand on
écrit pis dans cette base peine 7
en fait on va écrire des mots font des
études de lettres plutôt là vous pouvez
vous demander est ce que dans cette lui
de suite de lettres et bien vous pouvez
trouver n'importe quel mot à ce que ce
que mon nom par exemple quelque part
dans cette suite de lettres
merci pays est un nombre normal et bien
vous trouverez absolument tout dans les
décimales de pi fin de relais 27e mal en
particulier la bible serait écrite
quelque part dans les chiffres de pia
déclaration des droits de l'homme tout
tout tout tout est dans les décimales de
pi tout tout tout tout est dans les
décimales de pi tout tout tout tout est
dans les décimales de pi
donc au final ce qui est peut-être le
plus fou avec pi c'est que selon aussi
anormal
on le voit vraiment partout on trouvait
en géométrie en probabilités en analyse
ce nombre si anormal si atypique vers ce
nombre anormal très bien normal en fait
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
la plus noire parler de pluton la
question à laquelle j'aimerais que vous
réfléchissiez un petit peu c'est
pourquoi est-ce que pluton n'est plus
une planète
ou plutôt pourquoi est-ce que pluton a
été créé mais cette vidéo d'un partage
et la mettez un pouce vers le haut
mettez dans les commentaires ce que vous
pensez de cette vidéo avec quel est ce
que vous pensez de pluton est en bas
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois à partir de là archimède et est
donc en mesure
calculez l'ère du rectangle quelquefois
la séquence de chiffres que vous
cherchez dans les décimales cette
séquence existe dans des défilés